explain to us why the Scottish
government has attempting to change the
law here
actually given chance people
excess that's already in place to ensure
that trans people can obtain a gender
recognition certificate it demedicalizes
the process it takes away the need for
strangers on a panel to make decisions
about an individual that they've never
met and this is in fact a really good
news story this is progression in
Scotland making it a more fairer and
equal place to live and that can only be
a good thing it's explained to us why
it's important to take medical
professionals out of this process this
is obviously a hugely significant
decision that an individual could be
making
absolutely there's no need for this to
be medicalized trans people know their
own minds they know and understand what
they want to do with their lives they
have bodily autonomy and that should be
honored absolutely
I mean how do you answer the criticism
that this uh clarification of the
legislation as you put it is is in fact
harmful to the rights of women
absolutely well not there there is no um
there's no way that women's rights are
going to be impacted by this I'm a woman
myself I'm an intersectional feminist
and this in fact is good for feminism
overall is good for women because this
is progression away from archaic systems
and of course we have to remember that
trans women are women as well and we're
all in this fight of feminism together
there there should be no conflation with
anything else this is about trans people
and a process to simplify them obtaining
a gender recognition certificate to live
their lives with dignity and respect but
just just staying on the rights of women
this decision has been criticized by the
special rapporte on violence against
women and girls from the United Nations
I mean she's an expert in the field and
she's concerned about the changes well
we've had I'm a member of the equality
human rights and Civil Justice committee
and we had an Evidence session on Monday
which we were able to speak to two of
the UN Specialists and Victor was there
as well and I did ask her
um probably about three times to ask why
she changed her mind away from
supporting the model of self-id and
simplifying the process for Trans people
but what she did was write a letter to
Bulgaria in 2021 asking them to do that
um after three questions I really
couldn't quite get to the bones of the
evidence of to why she would have
changed her mind and Victor himself had
provided quite a lot of
evidence-based facts so for myself or
the other members of the committee for
the months of time we've taken on
evidence sessions on this you know I'm
very satisfied that there is no threat
to women and girls absolutely not and it
shouldn't be conflated with that yeah
it's not just a screaming in the U.N
that was disagree within your own
parties isn't as well uh Miss Adam but
also let's just go back to the idea of a
16 or 17 year old making such a huge
decision on their lives I mean I
remember I was like at 16 is it really
the time to be making such huge profound
life-changing decisions without the
support of professionals
yeah well I mean I mean just to pick up
on other members of the SMP group you
know it's a very small vocal minority
and that is done for them to to answer
for that we were elected on a Manifesto
commitment twice to past gender
recognition reform we took evidence from
the Scottish children's commissioner who
advised that lowering the age to 16 and
17 would be a good thing we're talking
about people who are going to be
transitioning out of schools academies
into perhaps the workforce and to
further education and to be able to have
a certificate in their gender and with
their their name that they want to be
called by is crucially important for
them and for their mental health and for
them to be able to take part in society
as the person that they know and want to
be
okay Karen Adam appreciate your time
this morning thank you no worries thank
you